this is the ar.drone from a paris-based
company called parrot and it is one of
the coolest toys I've seen in a long
time it's a remote control the hovering
helicopter type thing you may have seen
one of these before except it has a
difference it's remote controlled by an
iphone and it's got a camera right here
that beams an image in real time back to
the iphone you can control this thing by
tilting the iphone and touching on the
screen or if you let go of the screen
the thing will just cover by itself it's
got all kinds of complicated electronics
inside see some circuitry here that help
it hover and stabilize when you're not
telling it exactly what to do there's a
second camera under here which can be
used to identify objects on the ground
the guys at parrot have built this
thinking that this would be a really fun
way to play augmented reality games the
way it works is this you'd fly this
around and it could identify objects
that you might you know hover over or
things that you have to find or shoot
maybe even in combination with other
people flying their own AR drones I
think it's really neat it's getting a
lot of attention and should be out later
this year I hope they haven't said how
much it will cost so let's just hope
it's affordable